hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator
now in this episode we're gonna be
exploring some of the new Easter eggs
that have been added since last time
that we explored the Easter eggs so
there's a lot of them so we're gonna get
to them ready that's first off you gotta
go into the menu so I gotta press the D
key to disable copyrighted music
excellent good point
alright so what did I do
Oh God Oh God push another button not
particularly that one I'm just trying to
get panty shots somehow that works
excellent now I have miss Patty's I owe
you one for this favor yeah okay I'm not
a hundred percent sure that went exactly
the way that it was supposed to go hey
how's it going
is that bulimic ng bad time mode oh this
could be DK mode oh [ __ ] yeah yeah I
think I've done this before
Oh God
senpai whoa hey senpai you've never
looked better
have you been working out Oh senpai I'm
impressed by your incredible bicep oh
hey
at least your boobs are finally in
proportion to the rest of your body
normal a normal normal normal normal
normal normal normal
hi hey ah they changed it
Oh so they actually look like Titans now
and not just weird ken-doll like naked
people that [ __ ] it's good thing we got
these invisible walls oh thank you
builders of the city who built these
amazing walls to keep the Titans at bay
thank the Lord we are safe
hi friends hello hi yes good excellent
okay okay all right well that's still
just as disturbing as it was before
don't know why that happens okay I don't
know I don't know what this is and I
don't know what it does
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what happened I didn't do that
holy [ __ ] where's senpai
oh geez it's so sad oh hi
Oh God even the teacher can't withstand
me sorry I'm really curious hang on I I
am I'm very curious to see if I send bye
hi senpai I know you're too strong for
this oh I'm sorry oh I didn't think it
was possible to kill that boy oh stop
sprinting into me Oh God
oh my god I'm still nervous around his
oh no don't do it teach teach don't do
it
No Oh God okay well this is unusual
Oh send by to get hurt I never meant for
senpai to get hurt it was my beautiful
man
I truly am a monster oh geez oh god what
are you
Oh Oh someone remove these amazing
powers from me I don't know what this is
from but Wow oh boy oh boy
sorry sorry everybody
sorry oh sorry all right it's time for
my favorite the one that I've actually
been waiting for yeah okay I'm gonna
test this out and hi teacher
hey what's Adam over there whoa senpai
point me to your enemies where are they
going oh this is everything that I had
hoped for oh good I can't kill senpai
like this boozy boozy boozy oh oh
dad dad dad
oh geez oh geez boobsie boobsie busy
working let's go drop that yeah that's
fine hello who the heck is this person
who are you I've never seen you before
boy welp you punch just the same as
everybody
oh man boink
oh geez boink wait
boink oh geez boink wait boink
okay well then oh jeez it looks like the
lockers oh hey senpai just don't turn
around it's cool you're guarding why
teacher are you guarding that body
how about gate oh boy Oh alrighty then
well my job here is done okay so I
accomplished everything that I've set
out to do in this episode which was
explore all the avenues of silliness
that this game has to offer
in the next episode there's a new way of
eliminating a rival that involves
befriending them so in the next episode
I'm gonna be doing that and also let me
know in the comments whatever you want
me to see to see me do in this game so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you next video
No